la fièvre olympique s'est propagée dans
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce mercredi 13
septembre plus de 500 supporters
tricolores sont venus assister en direct
à l'annoncé du cio via des écrans géants
installés pour l'occasion
bah oui c'est important ça descend temps
que paris attend les jo donc je pense
que c'est important de célébrer tous
ensemble cet événement aujourd'hui être
présent pour cette première échéance je
dirais de confirmation de gio oui c'est
important on est acteur tous autant
qu'on est à chaque niveau donc oui pour
faire attendre ses fans jusqu'à
l'annoncé officielle des animations
sportives étaient organisées sur place
le rider de l'équipe de france jérémy
rencurel qualifiés pour les derniers
jeux olympiques à rio l'été dernier en a
profité pour faire des démonstrations
avec des enfants devant le public
c'est important parce que ça ça pousse
il a fait découvrir aussi le baby c'est
pas un sport très médiatisée notamment
la piste est un peu plus et du combat ça
fait connaître notre sport
après de longues minutes d'attentes le
verdict tombe enfin paris officiellement
désignée ville hôte pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 par le cio une
réaction extraordinaire une réaction de
joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti
lors de l'annoncé est maintenant l
aventure commence une aventure commence
c'est une aventure historique et ça va
être passionnant de vivre cette période
les supporters présents au vélodrome
national espère maintenant vibrer dans
un peu moins de 7 ans avec des médailles
d'or françaises
[Applaudissements]